so as a filmmaker just starting out your
primary goal is to figure out how can
you tell stories that people actually
care about how can you be remarkable how
are people going to remember your movies
what are you doing to ensure that those
people are out there and sharing your
movies and talking about your movies and
it could be that you're one of the guys
they're gals that has to make twenty
movies before you break through and make
that really awesome movie that
everybody's talking about because it's a
craft not everybody gets to start out
and have a hit our home run with their
first movie you know for a lot of
filmmakers me included you know it takes
a long time to really get something
that's remarkable do you think people
get that though because I think we all
see the Kevin Smith's and the Ed Burns
and the Robert Rodriguez and we think oh
well then if we're so interested in
their story they're gonna be totally
interested in ours and you think that we
kind of have to you know see what's
really going on in sort of the reality
of the situation and know that we've got
to give them something maybe more than
just our own life behind the scenes kind
of a thing yeah well I think when you're
a first-time filmmaker and you're not
known there's several things you can do
with a project and make you more known
one is to affiliate yourself with people
and get people involved in your project
that already do have a following even if
it's a few thousand people throughout
social media if they're well-known and
living here in Los Angeles I can name
probably five or six filmmakers as I'm
sure you could that that are in that
range where a lot of people in the
independent film community know them so
if they're involved in a project you
know they mate weed out or share some
emails or do something where everybody's
like Oh have you heard about this
project and suddenly everybody knows
about this project meanwhile you're the
guy orchestrating it and nobody's heard
of you so you're surrounding yourself
with good people and I think that's one
of the strategies you can use the other
one is to focus on subject matter that
people care about there's all sorts of
controversial subjects there's all sorts
of affinity groups one of my favorites
is skateboarding another one is Amba
movies and and karate and like all of
that kind of stuff if you were to come
to me and say I get this cool
skateboarding zombie karate movie at
first I'd pause and think that
sounds ridiculous but then I'd be like
oh I have to see that I have to see what
that's about and at least you got my
attention I'm not saying that you're
going to hold my attention the execution
has to be really good but at least you
got something going there with your
subject matter
you